these are three things you might not
know about Tom segora starting off with
his original career goal which was not
an entertainment at all growing up Tom
wanted to become a surgeon but after a
few hours of shadowing doctors at a
local hospital High School Tom had seen
enough I don't want to be a surgeon I
don't want to be a doctor becoming a
doctor wasn't the only job outside of
stand up that Tom tried to pursue when
he first moved to Los Angeles back in
2002 Tom's main focus was to become an
actor single Tom used to attend various
acting classes all over La where he
would work on his craft and search for
ass prey on actresses and acting classes
Tom has always been a ladies man with a
passion for huge whopping tits it's true
Tom Segura has an eye for nice knockers
and even coined the pet name big-titted
animal in reference to his wife
Christina come here you big titted
animal that's literally what you say to
me floppers slobbers tits triple D
wife come here hooker